when the prize was announced I wasn't at
home and that was deliberate I wasn't
trying to avoid the people from the
Nobel foundation or the academy but but
I was trying to avoid media attention
which I expected would fall over very
rapidly so I made sure to go out at
eleven in the morning with the
expectation that the announcement would
be maybe 1130 or something like that and
I also went down to the harbor area red
bra for a lunch went to an art
exhibition and came back home at about
three o'clock and i was told the news
first by a former neighbor who stopped
her car which overtook me as i was
walking home and came across the street
and said congratulations my daughter
phoned me from London to tell me about
the award and I said what award she gave
me the answer I expected so I then went
home and read and listened to my phone
messages